The mental health of elite athletes has been much in the news this year. In May, tennis star Naomi Osaka withdrew from the French Open and then from Wimbledon, saying she needed to focus on her mental health. At the Olympic Games in Tokyo, gymnast Simone Biles, the greatest of all time, skipped most of the competition because of a mental performance block. And sprinter Noah Liles, who won a bronze medal in the 200-meter dash, spent much of his post-race interview discussing his battle with depression and anxiety. the world has noticed. One media analytics company found that in the week following Biles' withdrawal
今年，精英运动员的心理健康问题频频登上新闻。5月，网球明星大阪直美退出了法国网球公开赛，随后又退出了温布尔登网球锦标赛，称她需要专注于自己的心理健康。在东京奥运会上，史上最伟大的体操运动员西蒙·拜尔斯因心理障碍退出了大部分比赛。而在200米短跑中获得铜牌的短跑运动员诺亚·莱尔斯，在赛后采访中花了大量时间讨论他与抑郁和焦虑的斗争。世界已经注意到了这一点。一家媒体分析公司发现，在拜尔斯退赛后的那一周里，
from the Olympic competition, more than 9,000 news stories generated more than 2 million social media interactions that mentioned the gymnast and her mental health. This media attention may be new, but the field of sport psychology is not. Psychologists were on the ground with the Olympic athletes in Tokyo, and an increasing number of professional and college sport teams and athletes at all levels now hire sports psychologists to improve their game. So what is sport psychology? How does sport psychologists work with athletes to improve their performance and their mental health? Is there a role for sport psychology outside elite athletics? How does it relate to performance generally? And how might the discussion around athletes' mental health affect the perception of mental health in the
在奥运会比赛中，有超过9000篇新闻报道产生了超过200万次社交媒体互动，提到了这位体操运动员及其心理健康。这种媒体关注可能是新鲜事，但运动心理学领域却并非如此。心理学家们在东京与奥运选手们并肩作战，越来越多的职业和大学运动队以及各级运动员现在都聘请运动心理学家来提升他们的竞技水平。那么，什么是运动心理学？运动心理学家如何与运动员合作以提高他们的表现和心理健康？运动心理学在精英体育之外还有作用吗？它与一般的表现有何关系？围绕运动员心理健康的讨论又将如何影响人们对心理健康的看法？
United States and around the world? Welcome to Speaking of Psychology, the flagship podcast of the American Psychological Association that examines the links between psychological science. and everyday life. I'm Kim Mills. Our guest today is Dr. Jamie Shapiro, an associate professor and the co-director of the Masters in Sport and Performance Psychology Program at the University of Denver. Dr. Shapiro is president of the Society for Sport, Exercise and Performance Psychology, a division of APA. She also works as a consultant with youth, collegiate, and elite athletes from a variety of sports, including gymnastics, skiing, snowboarding, soccer, and more. She has a particular interest in working with athletes with disabilities. In 2018, she traveled to Pyong Chang, South Korea,
在美国乃至全世界？欢迎收听美国心理学会的旗舰播客《心理学谈话》，该节目旨在探讨心理科学与日常生活之间的联系。我是金·米尔斯。我们今天的嘉宾是杰米·夏皮罗博士，她是丹佛大学运动与表现心理学硕士项目的副教授兼联合主任。夏皮罗博士是美国心理学会下属的运动、锻炼与表现心理学协会的主席。她还担任各种运动项目的青少年、大学和精英运动员的顾问，包括体操、滑雪、单板滑雪、足球等。她对与残疾运动员合作有着浓厚的兴趣。2018年，她前往韩国平昌，
as a mental performance consultant for the U.S. Paralympic team. As a former competitive gymnast and gymnastics coach, she understands from personal experience many of the challenges that athletes face. Thank you for joining us today, Dr. Shapiro. Thank you so much for having me. I'm honored. Let's start by talking broadly about what sports psychologists do. I mentioned two different things in the introduction. Athletes' performance and their mental health. How are those two things related and how do sports psychologists deal with both of them? Sure. So what I want people to know is that sport psychology isn't simply doing therapy with athletes. There's more to it. And a lot of that encompasses the mental performance that you mentioned.
担任美国残奥代表队的心理表现顾问。作为一名前竞技体操运动员和体操教练，她从个人经验中深刻理解运动员所面临的许多挑战。感谢您今天加入我们，夏皮罗博士。非常感谢您的邀请，我深感荣幸。让我们先从运动心理学家的工作内容谈起。我在介绍中提到了两件事：运动员的表现和他们的心理健康。这两者是如何关联的？运动心理学家又是如何处理这两方面的？当然。我想让大家知道的是，运动心理学不仅仅是为运动员提供心理治疗。它包含的内容更多，其中很大一部分涵盖了您提到的心理表现。
And so what we're trying to do with enhancing performance is helping athletes to perform consistently at the upper level of their capabilities. and we work on various mental skills to help them do that. Everyone has mental health. It's on a continuum. So we might say everyone is mental health, not everyone has mental illness. And then there's some places in between. So there might be clinical mental health disorders where someone would fit the diagnostic criteria, for example, in the DSM-5.
因此，我们试图通过提升表现来帮助运动员在他们的能力范围内始终保持高水平发挥。我们致力于各种心理技能的训练来帮助他们实现这一目标。每个人都有心理健康，它处于一个连续谱上。所以我们可能会说每个人都有心理健康，但并非每个人都有心理疾病。在这两者之间还有一些中间地带。例如，可能会有符合《精神疾病诊断与统计手册》第5版（DSM-5）诊断标准的临床心理健康障碍。
And then there could be subclinical mental health issues where someone is severely distressed, but maybe they don't fit the criteria for, say, depression, anxiety, OCD, et cetera. And then there are just stressors of the human condition. As you know, we all experience stress. And then athletes experience specific stressors to their athletic realm. And so people are trained in sports psychology also on a continuum where there are some people who are trained in that sport science. Some are trained in that mental performance aspect.
此外，还可能存在亚临床心理健康问题，即某人感到严重痛苦，但可能不符合抑郁、焦虑、强迫症等诊断标准。还有就是人类生存状态中的压力源。如您所知，我们都会经历压力。而运动员会经历其运动领域特有的压力源。因此，受过运动心理学培训的人员也处于一个连续谱上，有些人接受的是运动科学方面的培训，有些人则接受的是心理表现方面的培训。
and there's actually a certification called a certified mental performance consultant through the Association for Applied Sports Psychology. And those folks focus primarily on mental performance. And then there are licensed mental health practitioners. And some people have all of those credentials. And some people have one of those credentials. And so someone's education and training in this field would really help determine what they're competent ethically to work on with athletes,
实际上，应用运动心理学协会提供一种名为“认证心理表现顾问”的认证。这些人主要关注心理表现。此外还有持证心理健康从业者。有些人拥有所有这些资质，而有些人只拥有其中一种。因此，一个人在该领域的教育和背景将真正决定他们在道德上有能力与运动员合作处理哪些问题，
and performers. So someone like myself, I have a master's in counseling. I'm a certified counselor, but I'm not a licensed mental health practitioner. I am a certified mental performance consultant. And so the role with the teams and athletes that I work with is focusing on that mental performance, helping someone, you know, try to excel. They might have some anxieties or struggles in athletics. So I'm trying to get them back to baseline, but I'm really trying to get them to excel above what their baseline functioning was. Whereas when we were thinking about mental health or mental illness or just some of those subclinical issues, we're really trying to do some therapy to help someone get back to
以及表演者。像我这样的人，我拥有咨询硕士学位，是一名认证咨询师，但我不是持证心理健康从业者。我是认证心理表现顾问。因此，我与团队和运动员合作的角色是专注于心理表现，帮助某人尝试追求卓越。他们可能在运动中遇到一些焦虑或挣扎，所以我试图让他们回到基准水平，但我真正努力的是让他们超越原有的基准表现。而当我们考虑心理健康、心理疾病或仅仅是那些亚临床问题时，我们确实是在进行一些治疗，以帮助某人回到
baseline. So you could think of that continuum where are we trying to restore them to their baseline functioning where they were before the struggle or are we trying to get someone to excel above that baseline level. So I get that you're working on the Excel part. But if an athlete also has some performance anxiety, I mean, can you counsel around that, even though you're not licensed in that area? I mean, how do you stop yourself?
基准水平。所以你可以把那个连续谱想象成：我们是在试图让他们恢复到挣扎前的基准功能，还是在试图让他们超越那个基准水平。我明白您是在致力于“卓越”的部分。但如果一名运动员也有一些表现焦虑，我的意思是，即使您在该领域没有执照，您能对此进行咨询吗？我的意思是，您如何克制自己？
You know how to do it. Absolutely. So it's not just helping people excel. I think I wanted to mention that because a lot of people think, well, if I'm working with a sport psychologist or someone in the field or a mental performance consultant, there's something wrong with me. And that's not necessarily it. there's this educational part where it's almost like coaching the mental aspect.
您知道该怎么做。绝对可以。所以这不仅仅是帮助人们追求卓越。我想提到这一点，因为很多人认为，如果我正在与运动心理学家或该领域的某人或心理表现顾问合作，那一定是我出了什么问题。事实并非一定如此。这其中有一个教育部分，几乎就像是在指导心理层面。
We call it consulting in our field. But consulting on the mental aspect, and nothing has to be wrong with you. It could just be we're helping you, you know, excel even more. However, of course there are performance issues or performance deficits or anxiety, tons of performance anxiety, as you know. And then so we are trying to get them back to baseline and hopefully a little bit beyond. But it doesn't mean we can't address these deficits. just if it gets to that clinical point of those clinical disorders, we would want to refer to someone
我们在该领域称之为“咨询”。但针对心理层面的咨询，并不意味着你一定出了问题。这可能只是我们在帮助你追求更高的卓越。当然，确实存在表现问题、表现缺陷或焦虑，如您所知，有大量的表现焦虑。因此，我们试图让他们回到基准水平，并希望能够超越一点。但这并不意味着我们不能解决这些缺陷。只是如果它达到了那些临床障碍的临床点，我们就会希望将其转介给
who's a licensed mental health provider. Right. That makes perfect sense. So let's dig a little deeper into the mental performance aspect of sports psychology. How do sports psychologists work with athletes to help them prepare for competitions? What are the techniques that you use and are they different for different sports? Yeah, and it's going to depend on someone's theoretical orientation. of course, but there are some cardinal mental skills that we work on in sports psychology,
持证心理健康提供者。没错，这非常有道理。那么，让我们深入探讨一下运动心理学中的心理表现方面。运动心理学家如何与运动员合作，帮助他们为比赛做准备？你们使用哪些技术？它们在不同的运动项目中是否有所不同？是的，这当然取决于个人的理论取向，但在运动心理学中，我们确实致力于一些核心的心理技能，
and I'll give some examples of them. I would say a lot of work we do is actually around self-awareness with athletes and helping them understand what works for you and what doesn't work for you and how do we build on those strengths. So some of it is you're the expert on yourself. How do you, you know, become aware of what works and keep using it, become aware of what's not working and tweak what you're doing to help those things that aren't working. So self-awareness is huge. But some specific techniques, one, of course, is goal setting. So we want someone to have specific goals. It helps direct your attention and your efforts. And so we want goals to be good or effective goals. I don't like the word good, but
我会举一些例子。我想说，我们所做的大量工作实际上是围绕运动员的自我意识，帮助他们了解什么对他们有效，什么无效，以及我们如何利用这些优势。所以其中一部分是，你是你自己的专家。你如何意识到什么有效并继续使用它，意识到什么无效并调整你的做法来改善那些无效的事情？所以自我意识非常重要。但一些具体的技术，首先当然是目标设定。我们希望某人有具体的目标。这有助于引导你的注意力和努力。我们希望目标是好的或有效的目标。我不喜欢“好”这个词，但
effective goals as we say. So some people said goals, I want to win, you know. That's a good goal. That's an outcome goal. And that's good. And we want people to want to win. And we want them to have goals beyond that. So I focus a lot with athletes on what I call process goals that aren't necessarily, I want a podium, or I want a certain number of medals, or I want to win this game. It's, well, okay, how do you make sure you do your best performance? And then the outcome is what it is. Maybe you have a best performance and you still don't get that gold medal. And so we want athletes to still feel a sense of accomplishment, even if the outcome isn't what they want. So we focus on, you know, what do you want to do along the way?
正如我们所说的“有效目标”。有些人设定目标说：“我想赢。”这是一个好目标。这是一个结果目标。这很好。我们希望人们想要赢。我们也希望他们有超越这一点的目标。所以我与运动员的重点在于我所说的“过程目标”，它们不一定非要是“我想登上领奖台”，或者“我想要一定数量的奖牌”，或者“我想赢得这场比赛”。而是，“好吧，你如何确保你发挥出最好的水平？”然后结果自然会呈现。也许你发挥出了最好的水平，但仍然没有拿到那枚金牌。因此，我们希望运动员即使结果不如人意，也能感受到成就感。所以我们专注于：你在过程中想做什么？
What are the processes or techniques you need to do in your sport in order to have your best performance? So setting effective goals, and you've probably heard of smart goals. I know it's very catchy, but specific, measurable. You'll hear A very differently depending on the person. I like adjustable because I think goals should be flexible, realistic, and time-based. So goal setting is one thing. of course helping athletes with their motivation. Sometimes, obviously, motivation waxes and wanes.
为了发挥出最好的水平，你在运动中需要采取哪些过程或技术？所以设定有效的目标，你可能听说过SMART目标。我知道这很吸引人，即具体的、可衡量的。你会听到根据个人情况有非常不同的解释。我喜欢“可调整的”，因为我认为目标应该是灵活的、现实的且有时限的。所以目标设定是一方面。当然，还要帮助运动员保持动力。有时，动力显然会起伏不定。
And so helping them connect to motivation so that they can have the most effective practice, or we call deliberate practice where they're practicing with a purpose and getting the most out of their practice is important as well. I would say arousal regulation. I like to use the term energy management because some athletes laugh at the word arousal. But it's basically being a while. aware of both physical and mental energy and how you're spending it. And so for this particular sport or event, do you want to be really hyped up and excited? Or do you need to be really
因此，帮助他们与动力建立联系，以便他们能够进行最有效的练习，或者我们称之为“刻意练习”，即他们带着目的进行练习并从练习中获得最大收益，这也是很重要的。我想说的是唤醒调节。我喜欢使用“能量管理”这个词，因为有些运动员听到“唤醒”这个词会笑。但它基本上是意识到身体和心理能量，以及你如何分配它们。对于这个特定的运动或项目，你是想变得非常兴奋和激动吗？还是你需要变得非常
relaxed and focus and helping athletes realize where they want to be, but then giving them techniques such as deep breathing or relaxation or managing their self-talk to help get them to that level that they want to be at? And so I just mentioned self-talk. I'm someone who focuses a lot on athlete self-talk. So I'm asking them what they're thinking. Where is their mind? And is that, I like the word productive versus positive, is that productive for your performance? So we talk a lot about what are your thoughts? How is that affecting your performance, but also your well-being. There's the counseling aspect of it in there as well. Focus and concentration is huge, especially during competition. You know, what are your focus cues? I help athletes develop
放松和专注？帮助运动员意识到他们想处于什么状态，然后给他们提供诸如深呼吸、放松或管理自我对话等技术，以帮助他们达到他们想要的状态。我刚才提到了自我对话。我是一个非常关注运动员自我对话的人。所以我问他们在想什么。他们的心思在哪里？这是否——我喜欢用“富有成效”而不是“积极”这个词——这对你的表现有帮助吗？所以我们谈论很多关于你的想法是什么？它如何影响你的表现，以及你的幸福感。这里面也有咨询的成分。专注和集中注意力非常重要，尤其是在比赛期间。你知道，你的专注线索是什么？我帮助运动员开发
simple focus cues to help keep them present and focus during their performance. And obviously at big games, Olympic games, Paralympic games, there's a lot of distractions. It's a different environment maybe than they're used to. And so how can they still focus so that they could do what they're trained to do, despite all of that extra, what I call noise, in that environment that they're in? routines are really important as well, although they should be flexible because things happen that people can't always predict like a pandemic. But, you know, pre-race or pre-competition routines or something we work on to help an athlete
简单的专注线索，以帮助他们在比赛中保持当下和专注。显然，在大型比赛中，如奥运会、残奥会，有很多干扰。这可能与他们习惯的环境不同。那么，他们如何才能依然保持专注，从而能够做他们受训要做的事情，尽管有所有那些额外的、我称之为“噪音”的东西存在于他们所处的环境中？常规动作也非常重要，尽管它们应该是灵活的，因为总会发生人们无法预测的事情，比如大流行。但是，赛前或赛前的常规动作是我们努力帮助运动员
feel really prepared and focused. And then I mentioned cue words. That's kind of the during performance routines. Where do you want or where do you want your mind? What do you want to be thinking? And then also post-race or post-competition. routines are important. I think people think a lot about the pre and the during, but not the post routine. So what's your recovery like? And I'm also a big on reflection after training and after
感到真正准备好和专注的事情。我提到了线索词。那是比赛期间的常规动作。你想要或你的心思想要在哪里？你想要想什么？还有赛后或比赛后的常规动作也很重要。我认为人们更多地考虑赛前和比赛中，而不是赛后常规。那么你的恢复是什么样的？我也非常重视训练后和
competition. So I like athletes to think about what went well. Often they go right to what went wrong. So what went well and also what's worth improving for next time. So it's a constant learning experience. Even if they didn't have the performance that they wanted, they could still learn something from it and still gain something from it. And so that way they don't feel like that was a complete waste or that was a complete failure. No, that didn't go the way you wanted. You could always learn something from it that can help you improve for next time. In terms of team sports, I would say, so a lot of those are individual techniques, but we also work with groups and teams. So team building, we want to build team cohesion so that people can work effectively with each other, working on
比赛后的反思。所以我喜欢运动员思考什么做得好。通常他们直接想到什么做得不好。所以什么做得好，以及下次值得改进的地方。这是一个持续的学习过程。即使他们没有达到预期的表现，他们仍然可以从中学习并获得一些东西。这样他们就不会觉得那完全是浪费或完全是失败。不，那没有按你想要的方式进行。你总能从中学习到一些东西，帮助你在下次改进。在团队运动方面，我想说，虽然很多是个人技术，但我们也与团体和团队合作。所以团队建设，我们想要建立团队凝聚力，以便人们能够有效地与彼此合作，致力于
communication, working on leadership for those who are leaders on the team. And the same with coaches. We don't just work with athletes. We work with coaches on coaching education. And the coaches are the ones seeing the athletes all the time. So I actually think it's even more effective to educate the coaches on how can you implement these mental skills with your athletes on a daily basis? Because that's how they're most effective is if they're consistently integrated. So helping the leadership, whether that's coaches or leaders, on the team, that leadership training is also something we work on recovery from injury mentally. So often there's, of course, the physical rehabilitation that athletes are doing.
沟通，致力于团队领导者的领导力。教练也是如此。我们不仅与运动员合作。我们还与教练进行教练教育。教练是始终看着运动员的人。所以我实际上认为，教育教练如何每天与运动员实施这些心理技能甚至更有效。因为如果它们被持续整合，它们才是最有效的。所以帮助领导者，无论是教练还是团队中的领导者，这种领导力培训也是我们工作的一部分。从伤病中进行心理恢复。所以通常，当然有运动员正在进行的身体康复。
There's also a mental aspect of recovery and building that confidence, again, an injured body part, but also that they're able to do the skills that they were able to do pre-injury. These all sound really logical like they would cut across all kinds of sports, whether you're a figure skater or a football player. I mean, there were commonalities. Absolutely. And I would say in terms of differences between sports, they can be applicable to all sports, but different sports have different needs, they have different cultures, they have different languages. And so it would be important for the sports psychology professional to assess what are the needs of this particular team. And that's going to be different for everyone or what are the
恢复中也有心理层面，并建立那种信心，再次面对受伤的身体部位，同时也让他们能够完成受伤前能够完成的技能。这些听起来都很合乎逻辑，好像它们适用于各种运动，无论你是花样滑冰运动员还是足球运动员。我的意思是，它们有共同点。绝对的。我想说，就运动之间的差异而言，它们可以适用于所有运动，但不同的运动有不同的需求，它们有不同的文化，有不同的语言。因此，运动心理学专业人士评估这个特定团队的需求非常重要。这对每个人来说都是不同的，或者这个
needs of this particular individual. And of course, we can't be experts on all sports. I did gymnastics most of my life, so I know the language really well. But I work mostly now with Paralympic athletes. And I did not know much about most of these sports. So from observation, from videos, from talking to my athletes, you know, they're the expert on their sport. I'm the expert on the mental skills. And so it's a collaborative effort, we work together in order to work on and address their mental performance. But it is important for the professional to learn, again, the culture, the language of the particular performance area that they're working in. Well, speaking of terms, one of the terms I think we learned during the Olympics was the twisties, right, which affected Simone Biles. And in other sports,
特定个人的需求是什么。当然，我们不可能成为所有运动的专家。我一生中大部分时间都在做体操，所以我非常了解这种语言。但我现在主要与残奥会运动员合作。我对这些运动中的大多数了解不多。所以通过观察、视频、与我的运动员交谈，你知道，他们是他们运动的专家。我是心理技能的专家。所以这是一个协作的努力，我们一起工作，以致力于和解决他们的心理表现。但专业人士学习他们所工作的特定表现领域的文化和语言确实很重要。嗯，说到术语，我认为我们在奥运会期间学到的术语之一是“扭曲症”（twisties），对吧，这影响了西蒙·拜尔斯。在其他运动中，
something very similar to that is called the Yips. So what is happening when athletes experience this why does it happen and what can sports psychologists do to help people work through them? Absolutely. So I call it a mental block in gymnastics. The twisties, I had actually never heard the term before Nostia Lukan used it on NBC and made it go viral. But the twisties are a specific form of a mental block for twisting skills. But there could be other mental blocks in gymnastics. I've seen it with many teammates where all of a sudden they just can't tell me. backwards and it's something they've been doing for years and years. I would have something on the balance beam where I just couldn't get my body to go backwards sometimes. So it's very common.
非常类似的东西被称为“易普症”（Yips）。那么当运动员经历这种情况时发生了什么？为什么会发生这种情况？运动心理学家能做些什么来帮助人们克服它们？绝对的。我在体操中称之为心理障碍。扭曲症，在诺斯蒂亚·卢坎在NBC使用它并使其走红之前，我实际上从未听说过这个词。但扭曲症是扭曲技能的一种特定形式的心理障碍。但在体操中可能还有其他心理障碍。我和许多队友一起见过这种情况，突然间他们就是无法做后空翻，而这是他们多年来一直在做的事情。我在平衡木上也会遇到这种情况，有时我就是无法让我的身体向后移动。所以这非常普遍。
I want to put that out there. And then in other sports, the yips where, say, a pitcher all of a sudden can't throw a ball to where they wanted to go. It happens in golf. And it seems bizarre, right? Like how can someone all of a sudden not be able to do something they've been able to do for many years. And I'm not going to pretend to understand all the psychophysiology behind it. There are some physical theories. There's something called focal dystonia where it's a neurological condition, they say, where your muscles are overworked. And so all of a sudden, they just stop working. But what I would simplify it to is there's a disconnect between the brain and body, where the brain, for some reason is not accessing the motor programs that are stored there for specific skills.
我想提出来。而在其他运动中，易普症是指，比如投手突然无法将球投到他们想要去的地方。这发生在打高尔夫球时。这看起来很离奇，对吧？一个人怎么可能突然无法做他们多年来一直能做的事情。我不会假装理解其背后的所有心理生理学。有一些物理理论。有一种叫做局灶性肌张力障碍的东西，据说这是一种神经系统疾病，你的肌肉过度劳累。所以突然间，它们就停止工作了。但我会将其简化为大脑和身体之间存在脱节，大脑由于某种原因无法访问存储在那里用于特定技能的运动程序。
And also just getting a little bit more into the neuroscience. Again, this is not my area of expertise, but when there's a fight or fight response, when we're stressed, our cerebellum kicks in. That's our like survival mode. And so that's the dominant part of the brain that's working and not the cerebrum where our higher order functions are and things like logical thought and motor programs. And so there's just a disconnect between the cerebrum and the cerebellum as well as brain and body. So that's what's really going on what I would say and what I've seen. And I can't speak for Simone Biles. I don't know her and I'm not going to pretend to understand what was going on with her. But just in general, in terms of mental blocks, sometimes they come out of the
而且稍微深入一点神经科学。同样，这不是我的专业领域，但当有战斗或逃跑反应时，当我们有压力时，我们的小脑就会介入。那是我们的生存模式。所以那是大脑中正在工作的主导部分，而不是我们高级功能所在的大脑皮层，以及逻辑思维和运动程序等事物。所以大脑皮层和小脑之间，以及大脑和身体之间也存在脱节。这就是真正发生的事情，我所说的和我所看到的。我不能代表西蒙·拜尔斯说话。我不认识她，我也不会假装理解她身上发生了什么。但总的来说，就心理障碍而言，有时它们是
blue. And I did see an interview with Simone where she said, I thought it was just a fluke. Like I just lost my sense, her appropriate reception or her sense of where she was in the air, she thought it was weird and she's like, let me just do it tomorrow. She came back and it happened again. And so that's really common where it's like, oh, that's weird. And then it happens again and then it happens again. And then it just exacerbates and gets worse. And stress does all sorts of things to our body,
突如其来的。我确实看过西蒙的一次采访，她说：“我以为这只是个意外。”就像我失去了我的感觉，她的本体感觉或她在空中的位置感，她觉得这很奇怪，她说：“让我明天再做一次。”她回来后又发生了。所以这非常普遍，就像“哦，那很奇怪。”然后它又发生了，然后又发生了。然后它就加剧并变得更糟。压力对我们的身体做了各种各样的事情，
which do not help our performance, especially as an athlete. And so the more the mental block, happens, the more stress we get and the less we're able to access that part of the brain and body that knows what to do. How does your own background as a competitive gymnast influence your approach to helping athletes? No, I think I can relate a bit to what athletes are going to have compassion for them. I could think of things that worked for me, but I, you know, I've studied this for a long time. So it's not just about what worked for me as an athlete. That wouldn't make me a professional. That would make me a former athlete trying to help athletes. So, but it is helpful
这无助于我们的表现，尤其是作为一名运动员。因此，心理障碍发生的次数越多，我们承受的压力就越大，我们就越无法访问大脑和身体中知道该怎么做的那部分。您作为竞技体操运动员的背景如何影响您帮助运动员的方法？不，我想我能对运动员将要经历的事情产生一点共鸣，并对他们产生同情。我可以想到对我有效的事情，但我，你知道，我已经研究这个很长时间了。所以这不仅仅是关于作为运动员对我有效的事情。那不会让我成为专业人士。那会让我成为一个试图帮助运动员的前运动员。所以，但这很有帮助
to think back and reflect on what worked for me and what didn't. But also no, different things work for different people. So I really, if I'm working with a gymnast, I need to check myself because I have so much bias as a former athlete and as a coach that I have to be careful to keep that mental performance hat on versus jump in a coach mode and things like that. So it's actually easier for me to work with sports that I'm not as familiar with because I can really stay in my lane and focus on mental performance. But it's also helpful to work with gymnast because I do understand what they're going through and understand the language and the culture of the sport. So I can think of maybe what would have been helpful for me as an athlete. I didn't have
去回想和反思什么对我有效，什么无效。但也知道，不同的事情对不同的人有效。所以如果我正在与体操运动员合作，我真的需要审视自己，因为作为一名前运动员和教练，我有太多的偏见，我必须小心保持那种心理表现的视角，而不是跳进教练模式等等。所以对我来说，与我不那么熟悉的运动合作实际上更容易，因为我可以真正保持在自己的轨道上，专注于心理表现。但与体操运动员合作也很有帮助，因为我确实理解他们正在经历的事情，并理解这项运动的语言和文化。所以我可以想到作为运动员对我可能有帮助的事情。我没有
sports psychology services, even through college as a college athlete. I did have a coach who was very psychologically minded and would talk to us a lot about these topics and not call it sports psychology. But now looking back, I know that's what he was doing. And I think that's ultimately why I had an interest in all of this because I found it really fascinating. And fear is a big part of gymnastics. So understanding that fear and how to work through that is really important. But I think being a mental performance consultant and having been an athlete in this role. And one of the few people in an athlete's life that I don't want to say doesn't care about the outcome, but that's not the only thing I care about. And I do care about their well-being and themselves as a whole
运动心理学服务，即使在大学作为大学运动员时也没有。我确实有一位非常有心理意识的教练，他会和我们谈论很多关于这些话题，而不称之为运动心理学。但现在回想起来，我知道他当时在做什么。我认为这最终是我对所有这些感兴趣的原因，因为我发现它非常迷人。恐惧是体操的重要组成部分。所以理解那种恐惧以及如何克服它是非常重要的。但我认为作为一名心理表现顾问并在这个角色中做过运动员。我是运动员生活中为数不多的人之一，我不想说不关心结果，但那不是我唯一关心的事情。我确实关心他们的幸福感和他们作为一个整体
person, not just an athlete. And so even when I work with my Paralympic athletes, I say, I don't care if you meddle. I'm like, I care because you care, of course. And I'm going to be here to support you no matter what happens. And that's a relief to them because a lot of people in the system, their jobs depend on metals. I don't think mine does. And if it does, I probably don't want to be in that system. I do want to help them again achieve their best. But I, you know, I think it's a comfort to them knowing that someone in my role is there to help them and support them no matter what. And I'm not saying coaches aren't, parents aren't, but I hope that they feel that and me being a former athlete, I think that support, no matter what the outcome is comforting and hopefully helpful
的人，而不仅仅是一名运动员。所以即使我和我的残奥会运动员一起工作，我也说：“我不在乎你是否获得奖牌。”我说：“我在乎是因为你在乎，当然。”无论发生什么，我都会在这里支持你。这对他们来说是一种解脱，因为系统中的许多人，他们的工作取决于奖牌。我不认为我的工作取决于奖牌。如果确实如此，我可能不想在那个系统中。我确实想再次帮助他们实现他们的最佳水平。但我，你知道，我认为知道我这个角色的人无论如何都会在那里帮助他们和支持他们，这对他们是一种安慰。我并不是说教练不是，父母不是，但我希望他们能感受到这一点，而作为一名前运动员，我认为无论结果如何，这种支持都是令人安慰的，并希望是有帮助的
to them. So let me ask you, how is sports psychology related to performance in other realms? Say I'm a CEO about to oversee my first shareholder meeting and I'm terrified of making a mistake or I'm a concert pianist and I've suddenly forgotten how to play a Rachmananov concerto, right, that I have to perform in concert. I mean, how does a performance psychologist help in those areas. And that's what we say. I think the broader field should actually be called performance psychology and sport psychology should be under that umbrella. Unfortunately, it's like performance psychology is different than sport psych, but sport falls under performance, business falls under performance, as you mentioned performing arts. And also a large part of our field now is
对他们来说。那么让我问你，运动心理学与其它领域的表现有何关系？假设我是一位即将监督我第一次股东大会的首席执行官，我非常害怕犯错，或者我是一位音乐会钢琴家，我突然忘记了如何演奏拉赫玛尼诺夫的协奏曲，对吧，我必须在音乐会上演奏。我的意思是，表现心理学家如何帮助这些领域？这就是我们所说的。我认为更广泛的领域实际上应该被称为“表现心理学”，而运动心理学应该在该保护伞下。不幸的是，这就像表现心理学不同于运动心理学，但运动属于表现，商业属于表现，正如您提到的表演艺术。此外，我们领域现在很大一部分是
what we call high-risk occupations, including military firefighting police, obviously of those high-stress jobs, which have similar issues that we've been talking about and similar skills can be helpful in all those domains. So again, if someone forgets how to play a piece or has stage fright, I think that's another psychological thing that many performers talk about, we could do some of the same techniques that we would do with athletes, specifically, you know, you have to rebuild someone's confidence. So start with basics. So if they suddenly forget to play, let's go back to basics.
我们所称的“高风险职业”，包括军事、消防、警察，显然是那些高压工作，它们有我们一直在谈论的类似问题，类似的技能在所有这些领域都有帮助。所以同样，如果有人忘记了如何演奏一首曲子或有舞台恐惧症，我认为这是许多表演者谈论的另一件心理事情，我们可以做一些我们与运动员会做的同样的技术，具体来说，你知道，你必须重建某人的信心。所以从基础开始。所以如果他们突然忘记了演奏，让我们回到基础。
Let's build up the skill and the muscle memory. And it should happen quicker because it's there somewhere. But you basically start from the beginning and gradually increase the performance until they can get it back. And it would be similar with gymnastics or diving or any other sport where it's like, got to go back and kind of relearn it from the beginning and then slowly build that confidence. that they can do it again. I would say another technique to help with mental blocks
让我们建立技能和肌肉记忆。它应该发生得更快，因为它在某个地方。但你基本上从头开始，逐渐增加表现，直到他们能找回它。这与体操或跳水或任何其他运动类似，就像必须回去并从头开始重新学习它，然后慢慢建立那种信心。他们可以再次做到。我想说另一种帮助心理障碍的技术
no matter what the performance area would be if someone could watch a video of themselves doing it successfully or in the case of a musician listening to it and doing imagery at the same time. So kind of feeling themselves playing that piece, imagining where they're pressing the keys or feeling their body go through a twisting movement as they're watching the video.
无论表现领域是什么，如果某人能观看自己成功做到这一点的视频，或者在音乐家的情况下，一边听它一边做意象训练。所以有点像感觉自己在演奏那首曲子，想象他们在哪里按键，或者在观看视频时感觉自己的身体经历扭曲动作。
And again, we're just trying to, trying to reconnect that brain body connection that's missing. In terms of a business professional who's nervous or scared of making a mistake, it would be using similar confidence building skills, maybe again, doing imagery, helping them with that arousal regulation of like, what's your pre-performance routine when you're speaking to your employees or whatever it might be?
同样，我们只是试图重新连接缺失的大脑与身体的连接。对于一个紧张或害怕犯错的商业专业人士来说，这将是使用类似的信心建立技能，也许再次进行意象训练，帮助他们进行唤醒调节，比如，当你对员工讲话或无论它可能是什么时，你的赛前常规是什么？
So it's not just like, get up there and talk. No, there could be a pre-performance routine for that. I know I'm a professor, so I have to teach, and I try to do some things to help prepare before I go teach. Teaching's performance psychology, any sort of public speaking. And obviously, you know, obviously many people struggle with public speaking. So having those routines, practicing, getting feedback, video imagery, or just a few things that can help in multiple performance area. And of course, the stress management, the arousal regulation also just applies across many performance areas.
所以这不仅仅是“站起来说话”。不，那可能有一个赛前常规。我知道我是一名教授，所以我必须教书，我试图做一些事情来帮助我在去教书之前做好准备。教学是表现心理学，任何形式的公开演讲都是。显然，你知道，显然许多人在公开演讲方面有困难。所以拥有那些常规，练习，获得反馈，视频意象，或者只是几件可以在多个表现领域提供帮助的事情。当然，压力管理，唤醒调节也适用于许多表现领域。
As we've said a couple of times, you work with the U.S. Paralympic team. Can you tell us more about that work and how you got involved in it? And what are the special considerations when you're working with athletes with disabilities? Sure. I'm so happy to talk about Paralympic athletes. The Paralympics are coming up, August 24th to September 5th, and they're getting more TV coverage than ever. So I hope people check that out. But I actually didn't have much training in working with athletes with disabilities during my graduate
正如我们已经提到过几次的那样，您与美国残奥代表队合作。您能告诉我们更多关于这项工作以及您是如何参与其中的吗？当您与残疾运动员合作时，有什么特别的考虑因素吗？当然。我很高兴谈论残奥会运动员。残奥会即将到来，8月24日至9月5日，他们得到的电视报道比以往任何时候都多。所以我希望人们去看看。但我实际上在研究生期间并没有太多关于与残疾运动员合作的培训
training. I had some classmates who did it. And then as a supervisor of students here at the University of Denver, I had some students actually working with athletes with disabilities. But this opportunity kind of fell in my lap from being in Denver that some of the sports psychologists at the USOPC, you know, they couldn't manage all the sports and all the Paralympic athletes. And the high performance director of Paralympics at the time recognized that they needed more sport psychology support. So they reached out to myself and some of my colleagues here at the University of Denver and said, will you meet with us? We want more support. And so we met for coffee. And I always tell students, take the coffee meeting, see where it goes. It may go nowhere. It may go
培训。我有一些同学做过。然后作为丹佛大学学生的导师，我确实有一些学生在与残疾运动员合作。但这个机会有点落到我身上，因为在丹佛，美国奥委会的一些运动心理学家，你知道，他们无法管理所有的运动和所有的残奥会运动员。当时的残奥会高水平总监认识到他们需要更多的运动心理学支持。所以他们联系了我以及我在丹佛大学的一些同事，说：“你们会和我们见面吗？我们需要更多的支持。”所以我们见面喝了咖啡。我总是告诉学生，去参加咖啡会议，看看它会走向何方。它可能一无所获。它可能
somewhere. For me, it changed my career. I've been, you know, working with Paralympic athletes since 2014. After that coffee meeting, we got connected with some coaches and my colleague, Arturo We're Aposhfordowski and I. We work a lot together with several teams, as well as individually with teams and athletes. And so it took off from there. And like I said, it's changed my career. I've been able to present on it and bring more attention to work with athletes with disabilities. So we go to training camps, some competitions.
有所收获。对我来说，它改变了我的职业生涯。我自2014年以来一直与残奥会运动员合作。在那次咖啡会议之后，我们与一些教练建立了联系，我的同事阿图罗·韦尔·阿波什福多夫斯基和我。我们经常一起与几个团队合作，以及单独与团队和运动员合作。所以它从那里开始起飞。正如我所说，它改变了我的职业生涯。我能够就此进行演讲，并引起更多对与残疾运动员合作的关注。所以我们去训练营，一些比赛。
I do a lot of distance consulting. So when the pandemic happened and people had to do this teleconsulting or, teletherapy, I was quite used to it because the athletes I work with are all over the country. And so we did a lot of that video consulting already, although I haven't seen them in longer than I ever have. So that's a little bit strange. But I'm also supporting them remotely while they're in Tokyo. And it doesn't, aside from the large time change, it doesn't feel strange at all to talk to them through a computer. But, you know, we do some of the skills that I already mentioned, you know, goal setting arousal regulation, certainly with the games coming up,
我做很多远程咨询。所以当大流行发生，人们不得不进行这种远程咨询或远程治疗时，我已经很习惯了，因为我合作的运动员遍布全国。所以我们已经做了很多那种视频咨询，尽管我见到他们的时间比我以往任何时候都长。所以这有点奇怪。但我也在他们身处东京时远程支持他们。除了巨大的时差之外，通过电脑与他们交谈一点也不觉得奇怪。但是，你知道，我们做了一些我已经提到的技能，你知道，目标设定、唤醒调节，当然随着比赛的临近，
just talking about what that environment might be like at the games, how to manage those stressors or distractions that are specific to a games environment. And I always talk to them about, like, if you can just execute the plan that you've been training to do for those few minutes or few hours of your life, depending on the sport, then the outcome is what it is. And that's so much easier said than done, but we work. What are your plans? again, the pre-competition plans, what are your cues for during the competition?
只是谈论比赛中的环境可能是什么样的，如何管理那些特定于比赛环境的压力源或干扰。我总是告诉他们，如果你能执行你已经训练了那几分钟或几小时的计划，取决于运动，那么结果就是结果。这说起来容易做起来难，但我们工作。你的计划是什么？再次，赛前计划，你在比赛期间的线索是什么？
What are you going to do afterwards to reflect? And if you can get to that, that you've been training, and that's what we call it mental training. It's not like, well, I'm going to meet with you, teach you imagery, and then it's magic. It's things that should be integrated consistently and trained consistently, and that's when it makes a difference. I don't think I've mentioned this. another big part of my philosophy in theory and many professionals in our field is the relationship aspect, I call it, you know, client-centered or student-centered or person-centered, where I am showing care for them as a whole athlete and not just talking to them as an athlete, but what is
你之后要做什么来反思？如果你能达到那个你已经训练过的程度，这就是我们所说的心理训练。这不像“好吧，我要和你见面，教你意象，然后就是魔法。”这是应该持续整合和持续训练的事情，这就是它产生差异的时候。我不认为我提到过这一点。我们领域中许多专业人士的理论和哲学中的另一个重要部分是关系方面，我称之为，你知道，以客户为中心或以学生为中心或以人为中心，我表现出对他们作为一个整体运动员的关心，而不仅仅是作为一名运动员与他们交谈，而是什么
going on in your life that could be affecting performance and just supporting them as a whole person. But that rapport building, we call it, or relationship building, I think, is an essential foundation before just jumping into skills that they could use. And if you don't have that trust and relationship from clients, and this is general, this is, this is counseling 101, but if you don't have that rapport, you know, any fancy techniques or skills that you throw with them is not necessarily going to be effective.
在你的生活中可能影响表现，只是作为一个完整的人支持他们。但我认为那种建立融洽关系，我们称之为，或建立关系，是仅仅跳进他们可以使用的技能之前的基本基础。如果你没有来自客户的那种信任和关系，这是普遍的，这是咨询101，但如果你没有那种融洽关系，你知道，你扔给他们的任何花哨的技术或技能不一定有效。
And so what's been great with Paralympic athletes is I've worked with them for a number of years and we've built that trust and relationship so that hopefully they are integrating the things that we're talking about and they become effective, hopefully. Have you seen an increase in recent years in interest from professional and collegiate sports, leagues and teams, and working with sports psychologists? I believe so, and we have students, and so I hope there are more and more jobs from them, but there are certainly organizations have increased their resources here,
所以与残奥会运动员合作很棒的是，我已经与他们合作了很多年，我们建立了那种信任和关系，以便希望他们正在整合我们正在谈论的事情，并且它们变得有效，希望如此。您是否看到近年来职业和大学体育、联盟和团队对与运动心理学家合作的兴趣有所增加？我相信是的，我们有学生，所以我希望他们有越来越多的工作，但组织确实增加了这方面的资源，
and I would say especially with that mental health, the U.S. SOPC now added a mental health director who happens to be one of my good friends and colleagues, Dr. Jessica Bartley, and she hired a fantastic staff. So they basically added a whole new department for mental health. They already had sports psychologists who focus on mental performance, but also mental health. And they realized, you know what, we need some more extra support for this mental health aspect, especially with so many athletes speaking out about it. And then other professional organizations such as the NFL also now require every team to have a licensed mental health professional on staff. And so that's been, you know, it's increased jobs in the field,
我想说，特别是在心理健康方面，美国奥委会（USOPC）现在增加了一位心理健康主管，她恰好是我的一位好朋友兼同事，杰西卡·巴特利博士（Dr. Jessica Bartley），她聘请了一支非常出色的团队。所以他们基本上增加了一个全新的心理健康部门。他们之前已经有了专注于心理表现的运动心理学家，但现在也涵盖了心理健康。他们意识到，你知道，我们需要为心理健康方面提供更多的额外支持，特别是有这么多运动员公开谈论这个问题。此外，其他专业组织，如美国国家橄榄球联盟（NFL），现在也要求每支球队必须配备一名持证心理健康专业人员。所以，这在业内确实增加了就业机会，
but that's been wonderful to see in terms of support for the athletes. And I don't think colleges require a licensed mental health professional to be embedded in athletics, but we are seeing more and more departments as a result of some of the studies that the NCAA has done. done, increase their mental health and mental performance staff. That makes sense. I mean, certainly if you see results, that speaks very loudly. I spoke a little bit in the introduction about the tremendous media focus on athletes, mental health in the past year. Why do you think this is happening now? Why might athletes feel more empowered to talk candidly about the mental aspects of their sports and about their mental
但看到对运动员的支持有所增加真是太好了。我不认为大学要求必须在体育部门中配备持证心理健康专业人员，但由于美国全国大学体育协会（NCAA）进行的一些研究，我们确实看到越来越多的部门增加了心理健康和心理表现方面的工作人员。这很有道理。我的意思是，如果你能看到成效，那确实非常有说服力。我在介绍中简要提到了过去一年媒体对运动员心理健康的巨大关注。你认为为什么现在会发生这种情况？为什么运动员可能会感到更有底气去坦诚地谈论他们运动中的心理层面以及他们整体的心理
health generally. And I'm not sure it's so new. I think athletes have been speaking out about this. There have been blogs, there have been interviews. I think these really prominent athletes have come out and spoken about this. And there was a documentary of the weight of gold that many Olympic or Paralympic athletes spoke out about the mental health struggles that athletes go through. And so I think through these mediums of documentaries, of blogs, of interviews that more athletes are speaking out about this. And they're seeing this modeling from other athletes and saying, you know what,
健康问题？我不确定这是否是新鲜事。我认为运动员们一直都在谈论这个问题。有博客，有采访。我认为这些非常著名的运动员站出来谈论了这一点。还有一部纪录片《金牌的重量》（The Weight of Gold），许多奥运会或残奥会运动员公开谈论了运动员所经历的心理健康挣扎。所以我认为通过纪录片、博客、采访这些媒介，更多的运动员正在公开谈论这个问题。他们看到了其他运动员的榜样作用，并说，你知道吗，
I struggle with that too. And I think it's important to discuss this. And so that people don't feel ashamed or like something's wrong with them and that they do hopefully seek help and know that they're not alone. So I just think more and more of these prominent athletes are coming out disclosing some of their mental health struggles. And I hope that trickles down to the youth levels where they see, oh, that athlete struggled and I'm struggling too.
我也在为此挣扎。我认为讨论这个问题很重要。这样人们就不会感到羞耻，或者觉得他们自己有什么问题，希望他们能寻求帮助，并知道他们并不孤单。所以我只是认为越来越多的知名运动员站出来披露他们的一些心理健康挣扎。我希望这能渗透到青少年层面，让他们看到，哦，那位运动员也曾挣扎过，而我也在挣扎。
And so where do I go for help? And hopefully someone in their life can connect them to the resources they need. If it's more of a mental performance issue, going to people trained in that. And if it's more of a mental health issue or a mental illness, going to a licensed mental health professional. So in watching what happened with Simone Biles and Naomi Osaka, my impression from what I saw in red was that they were treated very differently in the mind of the public,
那么我该去哪里寻求帮助呢？希望他们生活中的某个人能将他们与所需的资源联系起来。如果是心理表现问题，就去找受过相关训练的人。如果是心理健康问题或精神疾病，就去找持证心理健康专业人员。在观察西蒙·拜尔斯（Simone Biles）和大坂直美（Naomi Osaka）发生的事情时，根据我所看到的，我的印象是公众对她们的看法非常不同，
that somehow Naomi Osaka was seen as more of, you know, Primadonna with a problem that people didn't understand. And Simone Biles, everybody kind of got that, oh, you know, she's the greatest of all time. And I mean, no wonder she's terrified, to look at the things that she can do. But was that also your reading? I mean, why do you think that would have been that people saw them in different lights? I don't know. And I don't know if Naomi Osaka speaking up actually helped normalize it for Simone Biles. And by the time Simone Biles came out and talked about her issues, they were like, oh, wow, this has been happening more frequently.
大坂直美在某种程度上被视为一个有问题的“大牌明星”，人们并不理解她。而西蒙·拜尔斯，大家似乎都理解，哦，你知道，她是史上最伟大的运动员。我的意思是，难怪她会感到害怕，看看她所做的那些动作。但这也是你的解读吗？我的意思是，你认为为什么人们会以不同的眼光看待她们？我不知道。我也不知道大坂直美站出来说话是否真的有助于让西蒙·拜尔斯的情况正常化。当西蒙·拜尔斯站出来谈论她的问题时，人们的反应是，哦，哇，这种情况发生得越来越频繁了。
I'm not sure of the difference. or there were certainly different reasons that were given for backing out. You know, Simone Biles with the mental block and Naomi Osaka cited just mental health issues and depression and the media, media pressure versus, oh, there's a dangerous mental block going on where if Simone continued, she could have broken her neck, you know, or something worse. And so maybe that perception of, oh, there were more dangerous consequences of this stressor for. Simone Biles, then Naomi Osaka maybe affected the reaction. And I don't want to dismiss also the sociocultural and political aspects of all this with, you know, they are women of color. And is there a different reaction for them versus if it was a white male? Like when Michael Phelps came out and talked about his mental health issues. So it's interesting to think about. I don't
我不确定其中的区别。或者她们退出比赛的原因确实不同。你知道，西蒙·拜尔斯是因为心理障碍（mental block），而大坂直美提到的是心理健康问题、抑郁症和媒体压力，这与西蒙如果继续比赛可能会摔断脖子或发生更糟情况的危险心理障碍相比。所以也许这种感知，即西蒙·拜尔斯面临的压力后果更危险，可能影响了人们的反应。我也不想忽视这一切背后的社会文化和政治因素，你知道，她们是有色人种女性。与白人男性相比，人们对她们的反应是否不同？比如当迈克尔·菲尔普斯（Michael Phelps）站出来谈论他的心理健康问题时。所以这很有趣，值得思考。我
have necessarily an answer to that. But I think that's an important. perspective that people need to think about is how they're reacting to people of color or minorities versus people in the majority. So last question. Do you think these discussions around athletes' mental health will have a lasting impact on mental health stigma, both inside and outside the world of sports? I hope so. And so many people look highly at athletes as
不一定有答案。但我认为这是一个重要的视角，人们需要思考他们对有色人种或少数群体与多数群体成员的反应有何不同。最后一个问题。你认为这些关于运动员心理健康的讨论会对体育界内外的心理健康污名化产生持久的影响吗？我希望如此。很多人将运动员视为
celebrities and look at what they're doing and model what they're doing. So I don't think this is going to go away. If anything, I think it's going to keep getting bigger. Just looking at the media attention, it got during the Olympics. I think it's just going to keep increasing in terms of media attention and more and more athletes feeling comfortable speaking out about this. And like I said before, I hope it trickles down to youth or less competitive levels of sport, that there are stressors there too and pressures there too, and that hopefully the stigma does reduce and people are more comfortable asking for help and knowing where to go for help. I think that's hard too, is knowing who's trained in what, and I know we had talked about this, the licensed mental
名人，关注他们的所作所为并效仿他们。所以我认为这种情况不会消失。如果有的话，我认为它会继续扩大。看看奥运会期间媒体对它的关注度，我认为媒体关注度只会持续增加，越来越多的运动员会感到自在地公开谈论这个问题。正如我之前所说，我希望这能渗透到青少年或竞技水平较低的体育领域，那里也有压力源，希望污名化能减少，人们能更自在地寻求帮助，并知道去哪里寻求帮助。我认为这也是困难所在，即知道谁受过什么训练，我知道我们讨论过这个问题，持证心理
health professional versus someone who's trained for mental performance. And there are people who are trained in both. And so it's just important for people in the public to know what professional is appropriate to help my child or help myself in this situation. So I do hope it reduces stigma. All this talk about mental health. And I hope it doesn't go away because it's such an important part of humanity and performance. Well, thank you for joining us today. It's been a pleasure talking with you. I think this is a really interesting conversation. Thank you, Dr. Shapiro. Thank you so much for having me again. You can find previous episodes of speaking of psychology at speakingof psychology.org or on Apple, Spotify, Stitcher, or wherever you get your favorite podcasts.
健康专业人员与受过心理表现训练的人员之间的区别。有些人两者都受过训练。所以公众了解哪种专业人员适合在这种情况下去帮助我的孩子或我自己，这一点很重要。所以我确实希望这能减少污名化。所有关于心理健康的讨论。我希望它不会消失，因为这是人类和表现中非常重要的一部分。好的，感谢您今天加入我们。与您交谈非常愉快。我认为这是一次非常有趣的对话。谢谢你，夏皮罗博士。非常感谢再次邀请我。您可以在 speakingofpsychology.org 或 Apple、Spotify、Stitcher 或您获取喜爱的播客的任何地方找到《心理学谈话》（Speaking of Psychology）之前的剧集。
And please leave us a review. If you have comments or ideas for future podcasts, you can email us at speaking of psychology at APA.org. That's speaking of psychology, all one word at APA.org. Speaking of Psychology is produced by Lee Wynerman. Our sound editor is Chris Kondyin. Thank you for listening for the American Psychological Association. I'm Kim Mills. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
请给我们留下评论。如果您对未来的播客有任何意见或想法，可以发送电子邮件至 speakingofpsychology@apa.org。即 speaking of psychology，连在一起，@apa.org。《心理学谈话》由李·温纳曼（Lee Wynerman）制作。我们的音效编辑是克里斯·康迪恩（Chris Kondyin）。感谢您的收听，我是美国心理学会的金·米尔斯（Kim Mills）。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。